tu es ici à propos d'Hermès son fils en
fait c'est plutôt important ouais
ouais je pouvais dire la façon dont tu as fait irruption
tu es tous impoli comme si tu étais Hermès
peu insulté tu ne m'as pas reconnu
mes sentiments auraient même pu être blessés je l'
étais '
Je ne sais pas si vous avez remarqué que vous avez tué
ce short comme celui-ci.
ou Zeus interdire les épées avec lui
ne serait pas la pire chose au monde
d'avoir une chose ou deux pour vous aider objet de
collection dévissez le capuchon cela
vous libérez les vents des quatre
coins de la terre maintenant vous me dites
que c'est  ce n'est pas cool maintenant
tu vas aussi en vouloir un
.